ambulances rushed to not just one scene
but three where attackers rammed into
civilians every police unit in the City
and surrounding areas were called in 18
people were injured one of them an
elderly woman died of her wounds but as
First Responders took stock of the
situation it soon became clear that one
of the attackers was on the
Run we have a police helicopter that's
in the air in order to to scan the
perimeter as well as special police
forces and other security agencies who
arrived at the location to secure and
make sure that our civilians are going
to be safe people were told to stay
indoors while The Manhunt was
ongoing police say the suspects switched
between three stolen cars as they rammed
into pedestrians in different
[Music]
places I was standing here outside a
restaurant when I heard a loud boom
immediately I ran and saw a car crashed
into the bus stop I saw children running
one limping on one leg While others were
lying on the
ground the suspects were both arrested
police identified them as Palestinians
from the city of Hebron in the occupied
West Bank who entered into Israel
illegally since hamas's attack on
October 7th all Palestinians have been
banned from entry into Israel
Palestinians in the occupied bank and
the Gaza Strip were only ever allowed
entry through a work permit Israeli
security forces have already raided the
homes of the 44-year-old and the
25-year-old Alexander buers Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer